in the introductory video to the
hardy-weinberg equation I gave some
conditions for the hardy-weinberg
equation to hold and what I want to do
with this video is go into a little bit
more depth and go a little bit more of a
discussion on the conditions for the
hardy-weinberg equation now just to
review a hardy-weinberg equation is all
about if we have a population with a
gene say for eye color and let's say
that gene comes in two versions one is
the allele that produces blue one is the
allele that produces brown if P is the
frequency of the blue allele Q is the
frequency of the brown allele well and
if they're the only two versions well if
you add the frequency of P of the blue
plus the frequency of the brown they're
going to add up to 100% or 1 and if you
square both sides of this you would get
this this expression right over here and
we talked about that this is the
probability or you could say the
frequency of being a homozygous and
homozygous for the blue this is the pop
the probability of being of having two
alleles for the brown and then right
here in the middle this is the
probability of being a heterozygote and
why is that well because you could get a
blue from your mom or and a brown from
your dad or a blue from your dad and a
brown from your mom so there's two ways
to get that PQ combination now the key
idea here is hardy-weinberg assumes a
stable allele frequency so let me write
that really big because all of these
other conditions that you might see are
really like well what are all the
different ways that you could you could
somehow not have stable allele frequency
so let me write this down
stable allele frequency stable allele
frequency so a lot of times there's a
temptation to memorize a bunch of the
stuff you might want to do that but the
more important thing is to get the
underlying idea and the underlying idea
is well will something somehow cause the
allele frequency to be unstable and
actually another way to say stable
allele frequency is no evolution no
evolution evolution is a change in the
heritable traits in a population and
that will include a change in allele
frequency and if you think about the two
ways that you could have a population
evolving well you can
you can have selection so we're going to
assume no selection actually there's
more than two ways you could have
genetic engineering and all sorts of
things so we're going to assume but the
the mainstream ways I guess you could
say we can assume no selection we can
assume no genetic drift
remember selection is certain traits
that are make make that organism more
fit for that environment
well those traits are going to be more
likely to be passed on genetic drift is
random chance changes in the allele
frequency it could be due to small
populations it could be due to members
of the population migrating or some type
of bottleneck effects of natural
disaster that really gets you to that
small population so that's the big
picture but given that big picture I
want to dive deep into some of the
assumptions that you might see in your
biology class just so you feel
comfortable with them and you see that
we're talking about the same thing so
the ones that I mentioned that
introductory video are no selection and
that's consistent with no evolution we I
also talked about no net mutation also
consistent consistent with no evolution
once again we don't want to change the
allele frequency if there was net
mutation one of those maybe some of
those blue versions of the gene get a
mutation and they're not there now maybe
a different version or they're not
definitely not blue anymore so the
allele frequency would change the reason
why we care about large population is a
set is mainly for genetic drift if you
have a very small population just due to
random chance it's it's more likely that
the allele frequencies can change
appreciably now other conditions that
you will often see is are things like
random random mating that weather
weather or organism has a the blue or
the brown version of the gene that that
doesn't make them any more or less
desirable to a member of the opposite
sex and if you think about it you might
say well isn't that a form of selection
and you'd say well yes it kind of is but
this is sometimes broken out as another
way now also no migration that you don't
have the population isn't isn't growing
by by other organism entering it or is
it shrinking by other organisms leaving
or there's not a mixing of population
between two populations and once again
it's all in it's all because we care
about stable allele frequencies now if
we want to go even further than that and
sometimes you will hear these types of
things mentioned although I just
mentioned the five mainstream things
which all boil down to stable allele
frequency no evolution no selection no
genetic drift but sometimes you know we
are assuming that we are dealing with
diploid organisms that you're getting
one set of chromosomes from your mom one
set of chromosomes from your dad well or
one version of an allele from your mom
one version of an allele from your dad
and you might say well how can you be
other than diploid well you could be a
there there are tetraploid populations
especially this can happen in plants
where you could get two sets of
chromosomes from your mom two sets of
chromosomes from your dad we are
assuming we are assuming sexual
reproduction that we're not dealing with
cloning and or just budding where you're
just a copy of another organism from
generation to generation we're assuming
that whether you are blue or brown
whether you have those versions that
that's not correlated with what sex you
have what sex you are so allele
frequency allele frequency same in in
all sexes in all sexes and we're
assuming sexual reproduction once again
we're assuming one where there's only
two sexes so you could you know if you
were to think about if you were to let
your imagination go wild you could
imagine a lot of other constraints to
put here or other ways that the where
you could no longer have apply the
hardy-weinberg where this is we have two
alleles we're assuming sexual
reproduction diploid you're getting a
mom from your mom from your dad and just
here all the conditions that help us
ensure that we have a stable allele
frequency now the one thing you're
saying okay I can you know diploid
sexual reproduction okay but isn't isn't
you know isn't there always a chance for
a little bit of genetic drift isn't
there you know just the history of the
world is that we have this evolution and
the answer is yes and so the the actual
reality is is that there's very few
places where you could point to very few
populations if anywhere you could say oh
that's a pure
we can purely apply hardy-weinberg there
but like a lot of things in the Applied
Sciences it's a very good approximation
for many populations and so that's why
it is useful